hi there today uh before i get into my
video i did want to mention
my video today is on patience but i did
want to mention the 90-day challenge
that we have launched at link
april 1st april fool's day and there
will be prizes uh details are available
at the website uh the idea is to get uh
people to challenge themselves to do as
much as they can
um
you know i i'll talk about patients how
we never quite
uh learn as quickly or become fluent as
quickly as we would like and it's it's
easy to get frustrated that's one of the
reasons why we have our statistics at
link so you'll see that i mentioned in
my video that i'm a bit frustrated that
i don't understand better but then if i
look at my statistics i see that i have
learned a thousand words of greek
which i didn't know before
i have created over four thousand links
those are words or phrases that i have
saved that i'm in the process of
learning and as i see them again i'll
eventually they'll become part of my
vocabulary i have read over 40 000 words
of greek i've listened to i don't know
how many 12 hours of greek and so if you
see these statistics you see that by
forcing yourself to be active
even though you aren't
getting quite you know you're not
progressing as quickly as you would like
you are making progress and so you know
that's part of that whole patience thing
so i would encourage you all to join the
90-day challenge and talk about it on
social media and see if we can get more
people committed to
for a three-month 90-day period of
concentrated effort to bring them up to
the next level and now here's my video
for today hi there steve here again to
talk about languages
if you enjoy my videos please subscribe
today i want to talk about the
importance of patience in language
learning
i've embarked on my greek language
learning
journey and i'm having to remind myself
to be patient
at the end of my video also i'm going to
speak in briefly in four languages
language language learning is sort of
exploring it's a kind of tourism and
right now i'm exploring greece i'm even
going to be there i hope in october
but just to change things around i'm
going to travel
the eastern end of the eurasian land
mass the western end of the pacific
ocean and speak in
i think in this order russian
uh chinese korean and japanese just to
you know finish this thing off
patience you know i find myself now
after a month into greek
and i'm enjoying these many stories and
we've got up to 28 now in our link
library
they also exist in our english library i
find them very good
i go over because they're they're in
three parts i think this is an
absolutely brilliant way to learn
languages because there's so much
repetition
and there's the positive negative
question
sid type situation or different tenses
different persons so it's very
reinforcing however if i leave it for a
while and then i go back all of a sudden
i can't remember i can't understand
and i realized that you know as much as
i'm enjoying these stories it's not a
matter of a month or two or three
it's going to be a long journey and i
have to remind myself
of how long it took me to learn my other
languages
china or chinese is a bit of an
exception because it was a full-time job
so i had you know seven hours a day
three hours a day of one-on-one another
three four hours studying at home at
least i studied like a fiend so there
after nine months ten months you know i
was able to write the british foreign
service exam translate from chinese to
english from english to chinese and
interpret and all those things
but
the learning that i've been doing in the
last 10 years or so has been an hour and
a
half
an hour an hour and a half a day much of
which is listening listening while on my
bicycle while washing dishes
finding the time to read and on that
basis it's taken a long time i have to
be realistic russian
you know
before i could really understand well
without having the ability to work
through the text it was years literally
years
um
now when i went to my second slavic
language it was still a year and even
then after a year i went to prague and i
spoke to a lot of people and i was doing
fairly well but still that was a whole
year
and and the similarly with ukrainian and
and uh polish that are related languages
where you already have much of the
vocabulary uh romanian as well went
fairly quickly although i'm not i've
forgotten most of my ukrainian or at
least romanian but there again you have
that vocabulary thing going but
with with greek where there are very few
identifiable words you're learning the
vocabulary 95 98 of it
from scratch so to speak
with no reference points in other
languages
uh it takes time so uh i'm going to i'm
hoping to visit crete in october
realistically i'm not going be fluent by
the time i go there unless i were to
spend you know six seven hours a day and
i simply don't have the time to do that
uh now when we go my wife and i to crete
it's actually part of a visit to israel
so
when we're going to spend a month we
haven't yet decided how we're going to
spend our time
but we're going to spend at least a week
10 days in crete because i'm interested
in the history of crete and i'm
interested now in greek obviously we're
going to spend a week or two in israel
and then we're going to go into jordan
so there'll be opportunities there just
to hear and to speak
uh hebrew and arabic and if anything i'm
more interested in arabic because it's a
much bigger language worldwide
than hebrew i'm hoping that we will have
our many stories translated into those
languages because i think that is such
an effective way to learn for the time
being we have the greek and i think
we're going to be up to 50 stories in
greek right now we're 28. uh i saw that
because we've asked for people to
volunteer to help us translate i see
there was uh at least one person
volunteered to do it in arabic
so if we can get five you know again
patience five and then ten
then i might have some smattering of
arabic before i get to israel but i have
to be realistic
patience patient patience when we forget
patients when we don't understand
patients when we don't advance as
quickly as we would like
i can't go in there and in one or two
months
be fluent in greek it's not going to
happen patience and therefore as i
always say make sure you enjoy it and i
enjoy these many stories
even patients when you know i've been
away from these four languages that i'm
going to speak in after my english
portion here and i'm going to make
mistakes i'm going to forget things and
you have to be patient and so some
people some people may criticize i don't
think so people are pretty understanding
but but you have to be patient it takes
time when you don't use the languages
you slip a bit although i've always said
you may slip but ultimately learning
other languages makes you better
at the
languages that you have been ignoring
for a while this is something i've
experienced that you're constantly
exercising your mind and then when you
go back to those languages you end up
being stronger in them however when you
first start speaking them you stumble so
patience is such an important um
you know ingredient that we all need to
have
as
language learners so i'm going to be
patient with my greek enjoy it and not
worry about the fact that i keep on
missing the same parts and the stories
as i listen to them
thank you for listening
bye for now oh and one last thing if
more of you want to come forward to
translate our many stories into other
languages please let us know i will
leave the uh gereen who's compiling you
know the
sort of the plan for the project i'll
leave her email address in the
description box so that uh if you want
to help us out in whatever language and
hopefully in your native language please
let us know and she will distribute the
work so one person doesn't end up doing
all of it then we can have five stories
here five stories there
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you